du kannst ja mal ein video machen so 40
sofortgewinne einlösen ja alter stimmt
das machen wir jetzt so hin mit der
ganzen schachteln ja heute hier in
dieser box sind schon 30 gibt's sofort
gewinne
das machen wir jetzt nächstes ausgedacht
und herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
video ja weil ich hoffe natürlich geht
es gut
eigentlich das ist sehr spontan leute
wir drehen hat sowieso ein bisschen wir
produzieren bisschen vor eigentlich war
doch so ein video geplant ich wollte
noch mal diesen handy automaten von
media markt testen
checkt das video auf jeden fall ab jetzt
noch nicht gesehen habe leider der war
einfach perfekt der scheide automatische
heute ausgerechnet heute defekt und
jetzt haben wir uns dazu entschlossen
noch ein weiteres video zu drehen und
zwar die fortführung von mcdonald's
monopoly du kannst ja mal kurz hinsetzen
das erste video hat 104 hunderttausend
klicks 120000 euro
und ich habe ja gesagt dass mir überall
hauptstraße dennoch museumsstraße
westbahnhof und parkstraße also es war
nicht raten die mir noch gefehlt haben
habe ich ja ein video gesagt und ihr
könnt mir dann auf instant schreiben
wenn ihr einen geschlossen hat richtig
habe original ohne scheiß niemand
niemand hat ebene straße tief braucht
das war nicht schon ziemlich krass was
mir aber viele geschrieben haben zum
beispiel wenn ich euch immer einen bio
verbot alles hat herausgefunden dass man
sein aktuelles monopoly nur pro mcdonald
bestimmte strafen bekommt also wenn du
zu einem anderen fans bekommen zu andere
straßen manche meinen namen es kommt aus
bundesland als glaube ich irgendwie auch
nicht deswegen fahren wir heute zu zwei
verschiedenen bakterien andere kleines
bisschen weiter weg auf und kaufen dann
nochmal verkehrstrassen ein weißes zeit
einfach am effizientesten ich will das
hier trotzdem noch mal gerne meine ins
tor postma vielleicht meldet sich doch
noch irgendwer also ich habe so meine
story geladen ich würde sagen wir fahren
direkt los ich wollte ganz kurz noch
sagen hier am 16.2 gibt klamotten von
mir und zwar zum beispiel
diesen bilder alex trainingsanzug kann
man hier mit logos auf die serie
eigentlich auch aus wie einem rapper
oder nicht wie leute und über das
einkaufen immer die bauchtasche jetzt
noch mit ja schon also das ganze gibt es
ab dem 16 12 hält wirklich sehr sehr
warmes brutalem ich trage nur noch leute
deswegen 16 ab zwölf erstspender die
ohren
wir fahren jetzt wartet man sich die
auch noch nicht gesagt haben ich habe
gestern dieses video gemacht und habe so
auf diesen shop verwiesen beim kollegen
da haben wir heute morgen die umsätze
geschickt ich das alter what the [ __ ]
also da will ich aber mal was von sehen
hab ich geschrieben also popstars haben
alle teams sauer cases gekauft
ja das auch selbst sind absoluter renner
wirklich also deutlich vor linke euch
sehr gerne mitgenommen aber meinst du
das bundesländern irgendwie also wir
haben wirklich selber viele leute
geschrieben dass ich auf jeden fall beim
nächsten mal nicht wieder zum gleichen
weg fahren sollten wir können es ja
wenigstens versuchen weißt du was ich
nur halt augen wirklich krass finde dass
niemand ja gerne einen von diesen
seltenen straße hauptstraße irgendein
bahnhof oder so hat ja keiner
das ist ja schon mal überlegt man das
video 100.000 leute gesehen
100.000 leute davon gehen 50.000 ab und
zu mal dahin und bestätigt was umziehen
ein günstiger kannst du noch nie
erzählen dass da nicht eine irgendwie
wird daran erkennt man ja wie krass
selten das eigentlich ist
hallo oder sehr krank sei ich fühle mich
jetzt auch gar nicht wir verlagern wir
sehen uns gleich
neben nun heute ankommen beim ersten
mcdonald's und schönen teil hört sich
ein bisschen nummern ich hätte gern 20
mal diese kirsch tasche geht das 20 mal
diese kirsch tasche geht das 20 kirsch
tasche ja es okay dann warte ich danke
nach vorne machen
so erst jetzt müssen wir warten zehn bis
15 minuten auf 20 geschlossen
also ich habe keinen hunger auf
klebstoffe ich habe keinen auftrag
das ding ist kritik gestoßen wie viel
hatten die letzten 15 stück so die sind
alle weg hatten im kühlschrank also die
kann man halt den kühlschrank lagern
sechseinhalb stunden später die ersten
falten
okay das ist ein ort und dann warte ich
danke guck mal hier geduldig standen
fünf minuten das heißt hier arbeiten
schneller
[Musik]
da ist auf jeden fall der ob
wahrscheinlich muss man krank ist kann
ja noch recht kilometer fahren müssen
die aus zwei stunden am stück gefahren
jetzt sehen wir sie bitten
jetzt gut jetzt wieder ach so eigentlich
wollte ich nicht
herzlich willkommen zurück was einmal
das hat ja so lange dauerte der verkehr
in köln
grausam um die sogar zwei browser wir
sind wie lange als unterwegs 1 stunden
zwei stunden 12 1 stunde 45 also einiges
schon kalt aber ist nicht so schlimm
sind ja noch gestoppt
ok dann möglich sagen machen das jetzt
im schnelldurchlauf ich hoffe wirklich
dass vielleicht heute was dabei ist aber
ich stufe ist wirklich sehr sehr
schwierig ein
vor allem vor allem weil er vor allem
weil auch wirklich niemand von euch
irgendwas hatte was ich brauchen kann
und das sind ja seid ja schon viele eine
thema viele eine million touristen jury
hatte den kanal abonnieren wir sind fast
eine million leute ganz kurz darauf an
ihren klicken weil sie nur sagen wollte
eine nachricht ist mir noch im kopf
geblieben da meinte jemand dass er einer
großfamilie hat und dass ein jahr
wirklich aktiv dann mitgemacht hat
wirklich auf da war und selbst der hat
nichts geworden also wenn ich mich nach
diesem video mit dem thema nicht mehr
meldet ihr könnt mir weiterhin sehr
gerne wenn irgendwas habt was ich
brauche ich schreibe es in die
kommentare mehr bei instagram schreiben
falls ich mich da nicht mehr meldet dann
ist das eigentlich quasi unmöglich dass
irgendwas zu gewinnen ich dachte schon
westbahnhofs monat bahnhof poststraße
haben wir auch schon und jack white
coats vermieter nordbahnhof und wiener
straße brauche ich weiß nicht ich kenne
ich mir dabei eigentlich bin ich schon
so münchner straße hatten wir letztes
mal hat 30 magisches straße aber jackpot
calls haben alle gesagt solltest du mal
ein geben trotzdem die clubs allein
geben gut das könnte ich vielleicht noch
mal vom sprachen lernen
apple weist du warst immer hier ist
grade seestraße die brauchen wir doch
aber wir haben den bus immer noch nicht
voll da fehlt nämlich noch die
hafenstraße okay da schon wieder sehr
straße als höhle mein exmann ich hatten
und die heute ist die zufälligerweise
dabei da die werden doch immer auf
lieferungen da jetzt achtung der märkte
kriegt heute wieder 300 seestraße
opernplatz goethestraße auch nicht
schlossallee parkstraße brockmann das
andere war wieder ein jackpot
rathausplatz der es auch halten selten
schon wieder rathausplatz sofortgewinn
ein mc sunday
der kommt in unsere box
du kannst ja mal ein video machen so 40
sofortgewinne einlösen ja alter stimmt
das machen wir jetzt so hin mit der
ganzen schachteln ja heute heute hier in
dieser box sind schon 30 gibt
sofortgewinne das machen wir als
nächstes
einige die ich selbst nie draufgekommen
juri pokrant alle waren dicke nach oben
wenn ihr da bock drauf habe und für juli
natürlich sie können ja schon anreize in
deinen song scream wieder rauskommt
opernplatz ja etwas allee und jackpot na
ja wir haben wir haben jetzt 10 oder so
badstraße
nein nicht westbahnhof mode rathausplatz
machte sich auch mit neuer straße
münchener straße aber mit sektor
industry co
sofort gewöhnt ist klein ich habe auch
noch ein killer dessen wieder die
gleichen opernplatz und güte straßen ja
das ist alles hier 100 badstraße
chausseestraße und noch ein sofort
gewinnt nur eistüte theaterstraße
sofortgewinnen ein cheeseburger
theaterstraße brauchen wir die noch nie
museumsstraße sofortgewinnen und
poststraße
das wird kommen der eigentlich badstraße
und jackpot sofortgewinnen und
opernplatz
ich glaube ich muss wirklich leute hat
keiner von euch ebene straße ich weiß
sie sind alle selten schickt mir die ich
gebe euch dann auch gerne der dmi das
schickt er kriegt dann hier das iphone
oder was auch immer bei den sachen die
ihm für die fehlen wird nur irgendwie
sehen dass es halt wirklich funktioniert
so nicht
ich dachte ich dachte gerade steht
museumsstraße aber wie gesagt für die
leute interessant weil wenn die sinnlos
geld ausgeben neue straße und südbahnhof
sofortgewinn und badstraße dass man das
jetzt schon das letzte was nicht
behandeln auch hier einst sofortgewinn
und opernplatz schlossallee und haut
nein wir brauchen westbahnhof jetzt ist
das das letzte wenn man es jetzt ist
sofort gewinnen wir haben uns auf jeden
fall schon über 40 sofortgewinne und
bahnhofstraße haben wir wirklich keinen
mehr
mann ich bin richtig also ich muss auch
realistisch sagen ich habe es niemals
gedacht dass wir heute irgendwann
kriegen was wir gebrauchen können es ist
halt einfach quasi unmöglich glaube ich
wir finden normalverbraucher ganze 105
101 nicht so eine scheiße macht ist es
unmöglich wie viel habe ich jetzt
ausgegeben letztes mal 80 dieses mal
knapp 50 leute wir sind uns noch im
video bei dem wir dann die ganzen
sofortgewinne aufmärschen ansonsten
abonniert den kanal instagram alex w
wenn irgendwas habt schickt es mir und
das war's vom heutigen video chat gerne
bei einem shop vorbei den ich am anfang
meinte der mégane heißt wenn ich da auf
jeden fall in zukunft immer neue sachen
kriege zum testen das war's haut rein
absolut zu nennen seien hier schon die
lange im kühlschrank da die sind länger
haltbar also macht euch keine sorgen ich
schmeiße nichts weg versprochen